now i think in case this gets awkward
later i think i should bring this up
now yes that uh john bishop you do have
a connection to tom cruise uh yes
yes you do yes uh yeah we do have a
connection because we were both
i was on uh top gear shortly after tom
was on top gear this is the star in a
reasonably nice car the star in the
reasonably priced car
and you did very well top i did all
right yeah yeah you're top of the
leaderboard
how did you do jon yeah here's the
john bishop yeah beat you two seconds
well done i'm actually through gritted
teeth
i left a bubble for this for this to get
abused
because what i have to do is may do is
tom cruise he was cameron diaz
and then and then ripper clinch his
fourth wasn't he rupert grint
yes
tell me that you didn't just beat us you
crushed us
that's 142.8 that's that's a good uh
full second and a half almost i know and
the thing is like you can drive cars and
you're interested i've got
zero interest in cars
you chose the wrong profession tell me
about it i came away from that thing and
i've
i should be in f1 because all it was to
me though was somebody give me a car
yeah and said it doesn't matter if you
crash it
this is great this is like being 17
again on my dad's insurance
just go round a track is that right
don't belittle it
don't fake it don't make it sound stupid
and pointless yes please
it's very serious it's actually not just
like there's turns like you gotta make
right turns and left turns